um gang this is hans kim here just
talking and walking
feeling good feeling alive feeling like
my skin is kind of pale and weird
but that's fine
uh i've been playing
a little bit of settlers of katan
there's me
with the green screen i have it's a
little wrinkled
um but let's see if i can get this to
pop up
okay so that there's that
and now there's the game of katan
that i've been playing
hopefully i can get it up on the other
screen
but this is just sort of
my
um
my thing that i'm doing is uh
playing katan online
i thought i was uh playing katan for the
friends
turns out
i don't really need the friends
i just like playing katan
oh yeah baby so now i need brick to
build a settlement i'm
this game is pretty slow
we're all at low points i need to go in
10 minutes i don't know how likely that
is to happen
but this is cool like i'm just like in
the corner right here
hey what's up
um i don't think anyone wanted to trade
with me i'm just going to keep bothering
them even though i can get it on my own
i'd rather get it cheaply through these
rubes
i uh
annoy them so much just asking for every
single trade this is so slow right now
it's probably because i'm streaming but
yeah i've just been playing a lot of
katan just been hanging out having a
good time
and i haven't streamed in a while so i
want to do it the reason why i haven't
is probably because i've been playing
too much katan and jerking off and stuff
i do have a girl now
uh so that's cool i'm girled up
i have a girl she's mine i own her
um
i tell her what to wear and
how to act in public
i always rock blue team for katan i
always rock black because it's the one
option that you don't get to choose
um
so if you have to go out of your way to
get it so it's less likely that someone
else is gonna be it
what up doug uh don't worry everyone i'm
back in the chat says dark dink here you
are nor i can't play katan online this
is
colonist.io
i'm currently in the lead i have four
points i mean i have three points that
other people can see but four points
uh in secret because i have one victory
card
i really hope that the people out there
are not watching my live stream probably
not but i have to go to a
uh photo shoot someone's taking my
picture they just
graciously
graciously
uh said that they would take my picture
so
i uh
i have to go do that or else i'll feel
bad because
i was gonna go to his office but it was
like 38 minutes away and i was lazy and
i was like
let's do it somewhere else so now we're
doing it at the vulcan
and i need to be on time for that if i'm
not i'm to feel so bad because i already
made them switch up and they're bringing
all their gear there
so i can only do it for 10 minutes i
have to leave at 6 30
but i just wanted to do it because i set
it all up
it's just
my setup right now uh [ __ ] i gotta build
a road or something right
um [ __ ]
let's go this way
let me just build around this eight
let me ask for a trade
hopefully i can get a trade
and then i can do everything on this
turn
but if not i'll have to wait
i just next turned it
so yeah i'm having a good time just
chilling out relaxing i don't know if my
camera's on a delay or something because
it's going through some [ __ ]
but hopefully it's all delayed at the
same rate
if the desktop audio is loud please let
me know
do i have any wood
is this okay because now i'm covering up
the scoreboards
but
i'm covering up my own scoreboard maybe
i could just reduce this a little bit
like that
then this is on display let me get rid
of that
and then it's the vulcan
it's a picture of brian holtzman at the
vulcan
look at me
hey here but for the play-by-play
brian holtzman bringing up the rear
of the
thing
oops
so yeah that's just my life
i'm open up for rogan at an arena so
that should be fun
i am excited about that it's a huge
opportunity i'm gonna be flying in a
private jet so in some ways
i am above you and better than uh and
you should
respect me
no i'm just kidding uh
i am honored and privileged to be in
this position and it can go away at any
moment so
i am trying not to be arrogant
um yesterday hung out with mark normand
shane gillis ari shafir greg fitzsimmons
in the green room and the or as i like
to call it the
greeny i was in the greeny yesterday
look at me
oh let's see how the delay is
um but yeah i'm having a good time
chilling relaxing there's the stop
button up there it's kind of annoying
um but uh
yeah
um having a good time
owning people at katan be ready have a
slap in your pocket now you got a girl
be ready have a slap in your back pocket
now you have a girl
yeah i like to have a slap ready that's
that's what i like to do is to hit the
people that i love
i can't flip the board online if i'm
losing that's true i mean this is so
much better than playing in person
because if you're playing in person you
got to set it up you got to wait for it
everyone
you know it's just a pain in the ass but
online it's just clean and easy and
simple
oh i forgot i have this three to one
port
that's good to know i need an 11 i need
this brick to come in
something fierce i mean i already have
nine cards you can't see it but i have
nine cards
yesterday was dope i got to hang out
with a lot of famous
super successful comedians
and that was really fun uh we don't
respect you hans
okay
um that's fair fair enough i don't
believe in robot dice rolls i mean
oh thank god i didn't seven myself like
a [ __ ]
let's see if anyone wants to trade for a
brick and if not i'll just buy one at
the market for market value
um
but yeah i mean
oh [ __ ]
okay i think i'm fine
oh someone robbed me this is only for me
who the [ __ ] put that robber there
[ __ ] chabast
he's jealous i have three points
what a cuck
what a kakaroo
um
you know i'm gonna take a risk
and
no i'm not
next turn
i was gonna be a brave man but i decided
to be a weak little slobbering little
boy
um someone got the longest road he's got
five points i got four points one secret
point three public points
um but yeah i mean i've been good i've
been hanging out a lot doing a lot of
joe rogan shows and now
it's kind of my thing like i don't even
know how to do a comedy show if joe
rogan's not on it
i keep mentioning a famous person and
then no one knows who i'm talking about
i need that leverage of a famous person
going on after me
i've been going up uh
first
for so many
shows i go first to kill tony i go first
at the joe rogan shows i'm paying my
dues i honestly would not want to go
anywhere else
because i'm afraid that i will bomb
after a very very successful comedian
so i am happy to go wherever
first that way nobody
knows at that moment that there is
better comedy to them i am the best
comedian in that moment
so you know
i
excel when no one expects any better
so i really
um
enjoy my position because then i don't
have to you know
be like no i swear i'm funny i know that
guy was [ __ ] murdering but uh i'm
also funny please believe me
please believe me
um
[Music]
or
this
either way
someone help me please these people
don't trade with me
they're not friendly folk
okay never mind i take it all back
let me get a brick
give me a brick brick
okay
here i am playing katan for
two more minutes
and then i have to go to this photo
shoot and get my photo taken
hopefully i look beautiful my skin's a
little
whatever today but what are you gonna do
like i feel like this
the desktop is at normal speed and then
this camera is delayed
so when i
highlight you can't see it right away it
takes a while
and that's frustrating because i want
you guys to see me highly
my respect for the fuhrer must be
documented in real time or else it
doesn't come off as authentic it looks
like i'm faking it
no but i uh don't like hitler if you
ever do a show in fort lauderdale you
got to play tan with your boy who's my
boy tsunami's tabletop is that my boy
that sounds like a gaming uh username
you'd play games a lot boy my boy
my boy
you're my boy
what do i want to do who am i why am i
here
what am i going to do
i would love a wheat port but the wheat
port is right here i could probably get
that if i tried let me get a [ __ ]
whatever
and then
let me
get
let me get a brick
nah i don't want to break i'm just going
to save these [ __ ]
i'm going to get a rock
because i want to build a city
eventually i'd only have uh three
which doesn't get rolled a lot in catan
well maybe i could have done something
different
i kind of want to connect this i can't
build here i can't build here
can't build here
so this would just be three roads just
to connect it
um
yeah i mean i'm having a good time did
you stop hanging out with gareth no why
would i stop hanging out with gareth is
he a warning is he a red do you see a
lot of red flags
thanks man i'm killing it thanks i
appreciate that you say it even if you
bomb it is still funny you're great
well you know
i wish i had your confidence
i could be like i swear this is funny
it's just
you're just not laughing because you're
part of the joke
bomb
allah akbar i am your boy
tsunami's tabletop is my boy
he's my boy
look what they did to my boy godfather
reference
look how many cards i'm getting so i'm
having a good time i'm just playing
katan i'm about to get my photo taken
it's 6 30 i should be heading
out seven
these [ __ ]
blue and red so i want to [ __ ] over blue
and red this is a good spot for blue
this is a good but for
that's a good spot for blue
let's [ __ ] over blue
see now
i have one rock
and i could have turned that into a
whatever
okay i got a brick
i could uh do this
my bam
then i can build right here now
because this is two away
uh let's see if anyone has a brick see
if i kept those wheat
unfortunately
um
someone needs a brick
it's me
so this is sort of my life now
i just play katan online
a couple red flags but he's fun he's fun
gareth is fun he's just a crazy little
boy
i mean i think gareth is like a
classic dopey white dude but
that doesn't mean he's a bad person
it just means he's dopey
dallas last week thanks for your comedy
you mean fort worth
uh thanks for coming that was fun
connect all six roads and then build
another road off the four wood tile
yeah i see what you're saying but
i don't know if it's worth it
i'm gonna build right here and then
try to come down here maybe get the
wheat port
maybe connect this
because the longest road right now is
seven i could tie that
but i'd rather get resource accruing
little doodads
then
not
i gotta go i gotta go take my pictures
and stuff
um the delay in audio gives it an old
school authentic asian feel wait there's
a delay in audio connect
there's a delay in video
this video camera is new it's very nice
but it's a pain in the ass to connect
i'm going to try to get rid of the delay
um but yeah 11 hasn't been rolled in
[ __ ] forever it's ridiculous
but thank you guys for
watching i hope to do it again it's all
set up i got the green screen behind me
so
um you know i can do this indefinitely
um
what do i want to do i want to build
let me try to get a wheat
and then i can build
a thing
or
this either or really doesn't matter i
need someone to say yes oh blue thank
you
thank you blue
i will be sure to subscribe to your
newsletter i mean this isn't a very
valuable spot but
i get a brick port which i never get
and when i do get a [ __ ] whatever
rock i can get to
now i just need a three
okay i gotta go thank you guys thank you
very much
peace